rumor has it that your jets fandom
started because your mom made you a
sweater everybody in my town has like
those old raggedy 1980s jerseys not the
stuff we all wear now and so I wanted
one but we moved to America I lived in a
studio apartment in Queens with eight
family members my parents were not going
to buy a $25 Jets t-shirt so my mom at
night knitted me a Jets sweater that I
would wear with the number five on it
cuz that was my favorite number and it's
always been my dream to buy this team
and in a stadium like this to put the s
in the front when people walk in and I
wanted to say you can literally do
anything from not being able to buy a
Jersey to owning the whole darn team I
have that ambition that Jersey is the
most important physical thing I have